I spent years trying to see all that
jazz on the big screen I see a lot of
movies and it's one of my absolute
favorites it's kind of a musical and
it's definitely sexy it reckons with Bob
Fosse the Cabaret and Chicago guy as he
chases his own ambitions rather than
cultivating relationships with the
people he loves because of that it's a
movie that all of us should see I had
the chance to see all that jazz on a
pristine 35 millimeter film print this
summer in Los Angeles the energy of the
crowd was infectious as we all took in
this beautiful film together even my
girlfriend who hates musicals because
they're not cynical enough walked away
impressed by the film I may never have
the chance to see all that jazz in a
theater again it's a Fox movie and after
Disney acquired Fox they've slowly
started pulling all Fox films from
theatrical distribution copyright lasts
95 years so this movie might not be in
the theatre again until 2075 now you
might not care about all that jazz but
what about alien or Titanic these are
classic Fox films and they might not be
in theaters again until after most of us
are gone ideas are too important for
someone to own forever the public domain
allows all of us to own creative ideas
like stories and characters the problem
is copyright keeps getting longer and
this is preventing new work from
entering the public domain imagine a
world where the idea for a light bulb
and its production has been owned by one
person since it was invented the world
would literally be a darker place the
light bulbs would be insanely expensive
and there probably wouldn't be much
innovation on the light bulb front now
think about a world where you have to
pay shakespeare's of state every time
you adapted one of his plays amazing
movies like 10 Things I Hate About You
West Side Story or The Lion King might
not exist if studios had to pay for
these rights thankfully these plays are
in the public domain so creators were
able to pull from them
to create any crazy thing they can
imagine but that's the added benefit of
keeping his stories and characters alive
plays and stories written in the 20th
century are not as lucky as
Shakespeare's this is because copyright
keeps getting longer at the start of the
20th century copyright lasted 42 years
this eventually bumped up to 56 years 75
years and 95 years through lobbying
efforts the result of this is that no
new work entered the public domain from
1998 to 2019 that's 20 years of stories
sitting on shelves when they could be
thriving before our eyes we've decided
that some ideas are not too important
for someone to own forever copyright
lasts ninety five years but patents only
last 20 that's tacit acknowledgement
that as a society we think that
transistors and telephones matter less
than our books and our movies I strongly
disagree with this i technology can
lengthen or improve our lives but to
quote author Joan Didion we tell
ourselves stories in order to live only
through stories can you step outside
your life and into somebody else's life
the public domain actually makes work
more valuable let's take a look at the
Wizard of Oz the original novel was
published by Al Franken in 1900 MGM
purchased the rights and in 1939 they
released that famous Judy Garland
adaptation
the thing is copyright was shorter in
the 20th century so by the 1970s most of
the novels and the sequels of the novels
entered the public domain this opened up
the floodgates for new adaptations of
The Wizard of Oz adaptations like sci-fi
channels Tin Man or Disney's really
bizarre movie Return to Oz these are
kind of creepy examples of the probably
working against my point but what about
something unimpeachable like The Wiz or
wicked I love these musicals and you
might too and they might not exist
without the public domain the public
domain has created far more economic
value out of The Wizard of Oz than just
royalty payments to Al Franken and his
heirs it's also kept his stories alive
Mickey Mouse represents a world of more
restrictive copyright terms Mickey is
ubiquitous you can find him on iphone
cases or dish towels you might even have
photos of him from your family vacation
but that's the problem
Mickey's no longer a character he's a
piece of corporate iconography what was
the last great Mickey Mouse cartoon I
would argue Fantasia and that came out
in 1940 Disney is not telling great
Mickey Mouse stories and Mickey Saul has
been trapped in the Disney vaults as
1928 there's good news though Mickey's
gonna be free in just four years his
copyright expires in 2024 let me tell
you what's gonna happen I promise you
Disney's gonna be just fine first of all
the copyright only covers the original
Mickey Mouse cartoons like Steamboat
Willie any updates to his character or
his design are covered under future
copyrights so they're still covered any
of the imagery that is used in corporate
logos actually counts as trademark and
that lasts forever
Disney's done an amazing job building an
intellectual property moat with
characters like goofy or Donald Duck
these characters came out later so the
copyrights are gonna expire later all
Mickey expiring is gonna do is
incentivize Disney to tell the best
Mickey Mouse stories they can on a more
open market now I'm not advocating for
an abolition of copyright I want to make
movies one day and I think creators
deserve to be paid for their work
copyright protects that right I also
recognize that it's probably impractical
to shorten copyright terms from where
they stand now I just want to make sure
they don't get any longer characters
like Mickey deserve to be free
remember ideas are too important for
someone to own forever
remember this if you ever have the
chance to work with content in your
career your instinct might be to hoard
this content by advocating for longer
copyright terms please don't do this
after 95 years stories and characters
are better off in the hands of everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you